i'm going to talk about improved merlin
author protocols for essential problems
in fine-grained complexity
this is a joint work with the cheyenne
akmal legit and malvika raj and ryan
williams i'm searching
so uh let me start by explaining the two
key words in the title learning other
protocols and fine-grained complexity
suppose we have two parties arthur and
merlin
suppose arthur wants to evaluate a
certain function but he only has very
limited computational power so he lets
merlin
help him compute the answer
to prevent him from cheating he also
wants merlin to prove to him that the
answer is correct
to do this
uh
we let
merlin sends the answer y together with
a proof string z of a length p of n to
other
then
other runs a randomized verification
procedure which runs in t of end time on
a word ram machine
then
we let this protocol to satisfy two
properties
the first is completeness if the answer
is correct then there exists a proof
such that the verifier accepts with
probability one
and the soundness requirement is
if the answer is incorrect then for all
uh proof strings the verifier should
reject with probability at least
two-thirds
we say the merging after time of this
protocol is the proof length plus the
verification time
meaning that we take into account the
time for reading the entire group string
and here we remark that if we require
the rejection probability to be one then
this protocol becomes a
non-deterministic algorithm
now let's look at fine-grained
complexity
in fine-grained complexity there are
several
central problems which are conjectured
to be hard such as threesome orthogonal
vectors and or pair shortest path
and based on these hardness assumptions
we can use fine grain reductions to show
a conditional hardness of many other
problems
and
recently there is some interest in
studying murdering other protocols for
central problems in fine grained
complexity
for example
let's look at the previous work of
williams which gave a merlin author
protocol for the orthogonal vectors
problem which is a central problem in
fingering complexity
here we are given uh two lists of
zero one vectors and we want to decide
if there is a pair of orthogonal vectors
and the
uh the best known algorithms for this ov
problem needs roughly quadratic time and
this is conjecture to be near optimal
williams in 2016
gave a merging author protocol for
counting the number of orthogonal vector
pairs and the running time of this
protocol is roughly n times d where d is
the dimension of the vectors
so this running time is near linear in
the input size so it's near optimal
and it achieves a nearly quadratic speed
up uh compared to the best known
algorithm
and this result refuted the merging
author's strong exponential time
hypothesis
and the algebraic techniques uh used in
williams results
have been applied in many uh subsequent
works for example uh the bjorklund and
khaskis protocols for many other
problems
and a sequence of results on
fine-grained cryptography and average
case fingering complexity
and here we consider
the following question can we get fast
learning after protocols for other
problems in fine grained complexity
and in this paper we showed the answer
is yes we can obtain near optimal ma
protocols for threesome and apsp
which are two other essential problems
in fingering complexity and we also have
many more additional results
so our new results in this paper can be
divided into four groups
and now let's introduce each of them
our first set of results is about the k
sum problem
where we are given n integers and we
want to decide if there exists k of them
that sum to zero
the best known algorithm for threesome
runs in
a roughly quadratic time
and its conjecture to be optimal
more generally for k sum the best known
running time is n to the ceiling of k
over two
in this paper we show that
certifying that no k sum solution exists
can be done in merging after time
roughly n to the k over 3 ignoring
polylog n vectors
so in particular
no threesome can be certified in near
linear m a time
we can compare this with the previous
results by carmosino at all which showed
that
no threesome can be certified in
into the 1.5 non-deterministic time
so
our results
achieve the better running time by using
the power of randomness in the protocol
our
our threesome protocol also has several
implications for many other problems
so let's look at the subset sum problem
where we are given n integers and the
target t we want to decide if there
exists a subset of them that sums to t
the best known algorithm for this
problem runs in 2 to the n over 2 time
and by a simple reduction
from subset sum to 3 sum
our protocol
implies that no subset sum can be
certified in roughly 2 to the n over 3 m
a time
this improves the previous result by
netherlands which showed a protocol in 2
to the 0.49991
and atma time
we also considered the closely related
mean plus convolution problem
this problem
is also conjectured to
require n squared time
and using the uh techniques from
vasilevskaya and williams
our protocol implies the following
the mean class convolution problem can
be computed in near linear m a time
now let's look at our second set of
results
which is about counting cliques
previously there are
several results on merging other
protocols for counting k cliques in a n
vertex graph and they achieved nearly
quadratic speed up compared to the best
known algorithms
and here we study a harder problem which
is counting zero weight k click
here the input graph
has
integer edge weights and we want to
count the number of k clicks with zero
total
weight the best known algorithm for this
problem
roughly takes n to the k time
and here we show that this problem can
be solved in m a time and to the ceiling
of k over two
so this is a quadratic speed up for even
k
in particular
uh when k equals four
uh we can solve the counting zero weight
four click problem in m a times n
squared which is
a near optimal for dense graphs
and we also have a improvement for odd k
on
sparse graphs for example when k equals
three
uh we can solve counting zero wave
triangle problem
uh by ma protocol with verification time
near linear in the number of edges and
the proof length near linear in the
number of vertices
our uh our zero triangle protocol
has implications for the apsp problem
where we are given a directed graph on
end nodes and we want to compute the
shortest distance between every pair of
nodes
our protocol implies that the apsp
problem
can be solved in nearly n squared m a
time which is near optimal
we can also compare this with the
previous result by carmosceno at all
which showed that apsp
had a end to the 2.94 non-deterministic
algorithm
again our protocol achieves a better
running time by using the power of
randomness
our third result is about uh k onset
suppose we are given a k c and f
uh the brute force algorithm for
deciding whether this kcnf is
satisfiable or not
runs in roughly two to the end time
but there are faster algorithms which
achieve an improvement of
a constant times n over k
on the exponent
here we are ignoring
factors that are polynomial in the input
size
and in this paper we show that
certifying that the kcnf is
unsatisfiable can be done by a merging
other protocol in
roughly 2 to the n over 2 minus a
constant times n over k time
previously the fastest
running out of the protocol for k onset
uh by williams needs a larger running
time two to the n over two
and this protocol actually solves a
harder problem of counting the number of
satisfiable assignments
and here we remark that
williams protocol algebraices in the
sense of aaronson and wickerson
and we can show that there is no
algebraising protocol for k onset in
faster than 2 to the n over 2 time
so
in our protocol we have to exploit
non-algebraic and properties in order to
obtain our improvement
our fourth result
is about quantified boolean formula
where we are given a quantified boolean
formula formula in prenex normal form
and we want to decide whether it is a
true
qbf
so this is a canonical p-space complete
problem with a trivial
algorithm that roughly takes two to the
end time
previously
williams gave a three-round
outer marine author protocol
which runs in 2 to the 2n over 3 times
here
the proof by merlin depends on the
randomness of author in the first round
and
williams asked the open question of
whether there is a merging author
protocol that
achieves a non-trivial running time
and here we affirmatively answer this
question by showing emerging author
protocol for true qbf in two to the four
and over five times
so these are
all the new results in our paper
for the rest of the talk
i'm going to describe our near linear
time m a protocol for the threesome
problem
uh let's first recall the definition
uh we are given input integers uh a1
through a n
and a threesome solution
is a tuple of three indices i j k
such that a i plus a j plus a k equals
zero
here for simplicity we allow repeated
indices among ijk
and our task
is to certify that
no threesome solution exists in our
input integers and we want to do this in
near linear m a time
so our first step is to
reduce the
no threesome problem to accounting
threesome problem with small input range
and here we are going to use the idea
from the previous work of caramel signal
at all
let's pick a positive integer d
and let's define a relaxed threesome
solution to be a
tuple of ijk such that af plus aj plus
ak
is equal to zero mod
d so
a solution
must also be a relaxed solution but a
relaxed solution may not be a real
solution
and because there are n cubed
tuples in total
we can show that there exists a integer
d that is less or equal to n squared
such that they are at most uh
other oto.n relaxed solution here we are
ignoring log factors
now uh in the protocol
uh the prover sends uh these integer d
back to the verifier and he also sends
the list of all the relaxed solution to
the verifier
and here let's use a m to denote the
length of this list of relaxed solutions
then the verifier wants to verify
three statements
first
the three tuples
in this list are distinct and they are
all relaxed solutions
second
none of these relaxed solutions are real
threesome solutions
third
he wants to verify that the input has
exactly m relaxed solution where m is
the length of this received list
if all these three statements are true
then the verifier is convinced that
there are no three no real threesome
solutions in the input
the first two statements are easy to
check
so it remains to verify the third one
which is a counting problem
since now we only care about relaxed
solutions
namely the three songs that are equal to
zero mod d
we can reduce all the input integers
mod d
so our new task is we are given
n input integers
that are from 1 to d
where d is
less or equal to n squared
and we want to prove that the number of
tuples that sums to
t
is exactly m sub t
and here
we'll repeat this for every target t
from
from the possible multiples of d
which are d 2 d and 3 d
and we want to prove the
solution count for each of them
and we want to check that
they
sum up to m
okay
so
uh in order to solve this counting
problem we are going to consider the
generating function of the input
instance
let's define a polynomial a of x
to be the sum of x to the a i
for all
input integers a i
and we have assumed that a i is at most
n squared so this polynomial has degree
n squared
and we consider a a of x cubed
and we use a b sub j to denote the
coefficient of this cubed polynomial
and we can easily see that
the number of
tuples summing to t is exactly
the th coefficient b sub t
and now we are going to use a technique
that is inspired by the previous work of
netherlands
let's define a set of numbers capital t
which is a
arithmetic progression of
a
common difference n
and it uh
includes
t and
uh it also includes all the numbers
that uh are equal to t mod n
so we can see that
uh
capital t has at most
3 n squared over n
numbers which is
linear in n
and now
merlin
not only sends his solution count m sub
t
but
also the m sub j for all the elements j
in capital t
and merlin claims that
they are equal to the correct
jth coefficient in a of x cubed
namely namely that he claims m sub j
equals to
b sub j for all j in capital t
and other wants to
check whether his claim is correct so he
picks a random element r from a large
enough finite view
and
checks the following equality
here the left hand side is a polynomial
in r
and the coefficients are given by merlin
and on the right hand side
is this is the corresponding polynomial
with the actual coefficient b sub j
and
by
schwarze polema
if
if the claim is false then other can
catch it with a
very good probability
and in order to check this equality
uh
he needs to
he needs to evaluate
both sides the left hand side is easy to
evaluate
so the problem is how to evaluate the
right hand side
here let's uh observe that
uh
if we consider a of r times x cubed
then this is going to
multiply an extra r to the j factor to
every term in this polynomial
now if we mod x to the m minus 1 then we
can reduce the
exponent on x
from j to j mod n
which means that
we merge all the terms
that have the same x exponent mod n
and recall that uh
the expression we want to evaluate
uh
is the sum of bj times r to the j for
all the j in capital t
uh
namely the j that are
equal to t mod n
so we can immediately see that
this expression equals the x to the t
mode n term coefficient
of this expression
so all we need to do is to
evaluate
this
and to evaluate this we can first reduce
the a of rx mod x to the m minus one
which can be done in linear time and
then we raise it to the third power
which can also be done in linear time
using fft
so
the total a time of this protocol is the
proof length uh which is
roughly capital the size of capital t
plus the
verification time which is also linear
in m so the total ami time is linear in
n
now let me mention several open problems
first can we certify no subset sum in 2
to the n over four m a time
in this paper we achieved two to the n
over three
second can we certify true qbf in two to
the n over two at any time
uh in this paper we only achieve two to
the four n over five
thanks for listening